you
[Music]
so today I wanted to talk about a new
package that I've been working on called
Victor's and this associated idea of
type stability which basically means
that ideally it should be easy to
predict what type of thing your function
returns but before we get into that I
want to talk a little bit about the
motivation in terms of some paths
how many of you heard of whack before ok
wet is like what or w-2 years but even
more surprising and there's a really
great talk at this URL that kind of
they've kind of created this term we're
talking about some of the really
surprising things about Ruby in
JavaScript and so I'm going to show you
some really kind of crazy stuff in our
and this is sort of motivation so I'm
going to show you a little bit of code
so here I've got two factors and I
combined them together and what do I get
what you might hope that I get an A and
a B and they're right and hopefully
maybe the output would be a factor you
probably did not expect to get two ones
out of that or what happens if I take a
date and a date time and combine them
together well it took me a while to even
kind of like figure out what was going
on here but this is the this is a day a
date and then the year four million two
hundred thousand ten ninety degree seven
on the 24th of January or what happens
if you do the other thing what happens
if you combine a date/time with a date
right again we get the date time that I
gave it and I get this weird date in
1969 what happens if you even look at a
date time the wrong way so what happens
if you take
a daytime and just concatenate it with
nothing and you lose that you lose the
timezone or whatever if you combined it
with a literal nothing and now oh you
get this random number so seriously
believe I see riously hope that no one
would argue that this behavior is
correct I think there's some kind of
good reasons of this there's not not
great reason but this sort of some
accident of history that have led us to
this place where we can get some pretty
surprising results from like pretty
unsurprising data types and a pretty
unsurprising operation see but so what
what's kind of what's even kind of worse
about this as I've just shown you one
function but there's a bunch of other
places we have to do this oh you've got
to take two Victor's of different types
and combine them together you get this
an unlisted R bind of F else and merge
and a bunch of other places and I don't
mean to just pick on base are here but
tidy verse is exactly the same problem
that some functions for combining two
victors together do something different
to other functions which is clearly a
really really bad thing and so the kind
of the motivation for this Victor's
package was to think about well like
what should we do this is clearly crazy
what currently happens like what what
how can we do better what should we do
and I think we can get some hint of that
by looking at the rules for C for
concatenate for atomic vectors because
the rules here are like pretty simple
and pretty reasonable and here I've kind
of displayed them in like in painful
detail if you've got a logical and
logical you get a logical if you've got
logical and then did you get an integer
and if you just list them all out like
this it seems pretty complicated but but
you can kind of display this in a table
form too so if you've got a logical and
a logical you get a logical if you've
got a double and a character you get a
character and if you if you stare at
this table a little bit
you'll notice that it's actually
symmetrical and that's a really nice
principle right because I mean
in this sense it means it doesn't matter
which order the arguments are you're
gonna get the same type of output and it
means you've got like a lot lists or
you've got less than half of the table
to remember now and that that also means
we can actually express it even more
simply we can express it as a well this
is technically a tree this this is a
very simple tree it's a tree with no
branches I'll show you a tree with some
branches a little bit later but you can
kind of do you can sort of work this
tree by if you've got like a logical and
a double say you kind of follow the
arrows until they meet up at a common
place which in this case is a double
right so you can just put your finger on
the two types and then follow the arrow
from one to the other to know which type
you're going to get and so now this is a
pretty simple summary of the rules that
base are pretty consistently applies to
atomic vectors and I think even if
you've never been explicitly taught this
you've probably like kind of picked it
up implicitly because this rule is
consistently applied the problem with C
however
arises that when we start to get to
these more complicated it's three
vectors which are built on top of these
atomic vectors that there aren't any
kind of simple rules anymore so when we
get to factors and dates and date times
and data frames things start to get more
complicated and it is exceedingly
different difficult to elucidate the
complete set of rules so figuring out
what the rules should be at least in my
opinion is the goal of this victors
package and I kind of I don't know the
thing I like most about this package is
possibly the logo which is very Tron
inspired so the goal of victors is going
to figure out these principles kind of
like once and for all to apply them
everywhere and the goal in some sense of
victors is a little a little bit weird
because I think if victors are
successful that there becomes this
consistency the rules the package itself
becomes invisible so my goal is that you
should never ever have to know
that this package exists but I want to
talk but unless you're a package
developed by unless you start to dive
into the details we can start to now
learn this this pretty simple theory and
the basic idea of victors is decay take
that very simple tree we had before that
that line and basically kind of turn it
into a forest so again the same
principles apply if you want to combine
two types of Viktor you put your finger
on each one and then you follow the
arrows so you will notice however that
this is not like a tree this is a forest
some of the things are not connected you
cannot put your finger on factor and
double and find any way to go between
them and I think this is really really
important there are some coercion that
simply do not exist you it does not
there's no way at that it makes sense to
combine a factor and a date-time
together instead of like trying to do
something trying to guess or what you
mean it's much safer to get an error
that forces you to confront the fact
that you've got a mix of weird data fret
weird data types you have to deal with
that yourself so I'm going to do a
little demo of this no live demos are
always risky but this should be fairly
safe so I've got the victors package
loaded and basically I'm gonna show you
this function called Vic underscore C
which is basically the same as the C
function you're familiar with from base
R but a basis consistent set of rules so
if I get a logical and integer together
or logical and a double together meaning
a double if I take a double and an
integer I get a double right these are
the kind of the rules that you're
already familiar with you don't even
have to think about them it is a little
bit constrictor about coercing two
character vectors so if you try and
combine a double and a
character Gila you've got an error this
is unlike besar right where you can just
combine these things that are a little
bit different together and I will just
kind of do it for you so so Victor's is
a little bit more strict in general
because it has this kind of escape hatch
all of these vectors functions allow you
to declare the desired prototype of the
output so here I can say actually I want
the output to be a prototype this
character type and I call this kind of a
prototype because you don't give it a
name of a type you give it like an
example of a type so here I'm saying I
make sure the output looks like a empty
character Victor and so I can do that
and now instead of implicitly coercing
Victor's to a common type here we're
going to explicitly cast to the type
that we have provided it so now we have
this consistent way that you can say I
want to make sure the output is a
character Victor and it will either be a
character Victor or you will get an
error you will never get any other type
of output when you call the function in
this way so again we get the same kind
of similar property with factors we can
combine them together we always get a
factor back now note the order in which
we combine the fact is important because
the levels are different right so if I
combine a and B first the levels are a
and then B if I combine B then a the
levels are in the opposite order so it
turns out it's kind of not possible to
be like completely symmetric because the
only option here if I wanted to be
completely symmetric as I think I'd have
to sort the sort the factor levels which
seems like a really really bad idea and
not very useful so the thinking behind
Victor's is kind of a combination of
like philosophy and pragmatics there are
some things that would just be like
maybe kind of philosophically more
beautiful or more pure but pragmatically
would just cause you a bunch more pain
when trying to use this in your code and
so Victor's tries to kind of balance
those things tries to steer you in a
direction of greater safety of greater
strictness of this idea of type
stability which
come back to shortly in a way from just
kind of always working doing whatever
whatever happens so the same thing
worked with ordered factors if you try
and combine a factor and an ordered
factor you're gonna get an error you can
combine factors and characters or again
you've always got this escape hatch you
can say if there isn't an automatic
coercion that exists I can always say I
want the output to be off this time so
again victus is going to be more likely
to give you errors than besar is because
it gives you the standard way of
resolving those errors by explicitly
declaring the type of output that you
want then again with dates and date
times this is like basically the most
boring demo ever because it just does
what you want I think any reasonable
person would expect it to do if you
combine dates and date times together
you don't get crazy dates over on the
future far in the past and if you just
concatenate a single vector with itself
then the time zones unchanged and then
when you try and combine different
things and base I kind of showed you a
few of these before but if you combine a
victor date time you can integer if you
combine a date time and effect you get a
date time a date with a weird date I
mean Victor's just always gives you an
error and again then this is always this
other kind of one last escape hatch like
what happens if you really do want to
combine a date time and a factor into a
single victor well you can always fall
back to a list because a list and I can
contain anything else so we can always
say make sure the output is a list and
we'll just combine all these things
together
so the the kind of underlying idea
behind Victor's is this idea of type
stability which I'm still trying to
figure out how to express a tic late as
clearly as possible but I think this is
this principle the way I sort of think
about it is like when when you're
reading our code what you are actually
doing is running that our code in your
internal mental model of our and
obviously your internal mental model of
our is much much simpler than the real
thing but I think in your internal
mental model of our one thing that's
really useful to think about is the type
of each variable and I noticed that when
I read other people's code when I'm
reviewing pull requests for example if I
read the code and look at a variable and
I have no idea what type of variable it
is
I don't know if it's a list or a
character or a data frame that code just
feels very dangerous to me because I
cannot accurately predict what's going
to happen so the first principle of type
stability is that the output type should
only depend on the types of the inputs
and so one kind of violation of this and
besar is the if-else function so here
I've got three calls to if-else the
first argument is always logical the
second argument is always an integer the
third argument is always a character
vector and yet depending on the value of
the logical vicked
the victor the output could be a logical
vector it could be a double vector it
could be a character Victor and I think
this is an undesirable property because
when you read code that involves if-else
it makes it hard to know what type of
output you're going to get and I again I
don't want to say like the typhus is
perfect it's far from perfect deep lie
if-else actually is equally annoying but
in the opposite direction it's like too
strict which forces you if you want to
insert a missing value to know about all
of these different types of missing
values that you should never be forced
to confront and that's pretty annoying
the second principle is that if you're
just combining a bunch of victors or
your argument has dot dot dot in that
your function is dot dot dot on it the
order of the inputs should not affect
the output
so I kind of showed you an example of
this already lots of examples of this
with C but ideally the order in which
you supply arguments to C should not
affect the output this is the idea that
gave us that symmetry in the table this
makes predicting the output much much
much simpler because there's just a much
smaller set of rules that you need to
remember and internalize and again
they're kind of the goal here is not
that you should ever have to explicitly
memorize the rules but hopefully by
having the small set of like reasonable
and consistent rules you will just come
to learn them over time and when you
predict when you like gifts you're naive
gifts about what a function return'
should just be more accurate from the
get-go and then the final principle is
almost so obvious that you shouldn't
have to recognize you don't have to say
it and that is ideally there should be
one set of rules that is applied
everywhere so again just to illustrate
this
if you concatenate two factors together
you get an integer vector but if you put
those factors together and a list and
then you 'unless them you will get a
factor as you expect it so the fact that
we have these inconsistencies just makes
it hard to build up that accurate mental
model and it gets confusing and I think
there's sort of both it's like
first-order effect that when you like
look at some code you're like I don't
know what this is gonna return but you
also get the second-order effect that's
even worse that over time you sort of
get this like learned helplessness
you're like I have no idea I've been
burned so many times before I've got no
idea what this is gonna return so I'm
just not even gonna try to guess which i
think is even more harmful now victors
does a bunch of other things which I
want to talk about briefly max really
really really wants to give me the the
gong if I talk too long so I don't want
to make him too happy but I want to talk
about briefly these other these other
these other parts of vectors so one
thing that I have recently discovered
about data frames is that you can have a
column of a data frame that is itself a
data frame
and this is like it this is supported
and besar so here I'm creating a data
frame and then I'm making a column of
that data frame that is itself a data
frame and you may ask yourself well why
on earth would I ever do such a crazy
thing and I don't really have a great
answer for you right now but it seems
pretty cool and like it might be useful
and so I thought it would be worthwhile
to kind of work through all of the
implications of that and so that's one
of the things that victus does another
thing very closely related to type
stability is this idea that I called
size stability this is basically kind of
the recycling rules of besar that you
know if you combine a victor that is Vic
to when you combine two victors of
different lengths there are these things
in are called the recycling rules which
determine what's going to happen I think
those recycling rules are like a really
good idea but they have two floors the
first floor is that they will recycle
like if you combine a vector of length
two and a vector of length three you
will combine the victor of length two
like a non integer number of times which
i think is just a little bit too clever
in most cases and the other problem with
the recycling rules if you sort of start
looking into them with a fine-tooth comb
you discover there isn't actually one
set of recycling rules is actually like
four sets of recycling rules that are
very subtly different so again the idea
of these kind of size table functions is
given these sizes of the inputs you
should be able to easy predict the size
of the output and then finally the last
feature in victors is that we should
have easier ways to create new types new
victor classes so if you have ever tried
to create a new type of victor and are
something like a factor or a date/time
currently it's really painful you need
to understand a lot about the history
object system you've got to define
methods for a lot of different generics
Victor's also provides some support so
that when you create new types of
Victor's there's some clear
documentation you need if you want to do
your if you want your vector to do this
you need to define these methods if you
wanted to do that you need to define
these other methods so if you want to
learn more about Victor's
two places to start other Victor's
website itself which has a lot of very
detailed information about how that
package works which is not that
accessible right now but will hopefully
get a little easier to understand over
time and then there's also more
information about it and the victors
chapter of advanced are one of the big
goals of the tidy verse in 2019 is to
thoroughly integrate these ideas one
last thing before I go and that is if
you are interested in working with our
studio and the tiny voice of SHINee team
we are having an internship program
again this year we'll have about 10
interns and pay positions over the
summer you have to be able to work in
the u.s. that we're trying to work on
international students next year if you
would like to find out more apply go to
this URL thank you
[Applause]
we probably have time for one or two
questions while we switch over mics so
if you've got a question wave your hand
and someone will throw a mic to you or a
you yes this is really exciting but I
think one of the things I always
struggle with when we talk about these
things is is I feel like in kind of just
like the community we don't like a great
concrete definition of what we're
talking about when we say type in terms
of like does the metadata matter for the
type are we just talking about like
built-in types are we talking about
classes yeah right like are there like
resources or like some kind of like
common language we're developing what we
mean by this stuff yeah so that's
another another aspect of the victors
package is this idea of the prototype
which I just kind of glossed over here
but the goal of that is to provide this
a consistent and concrete discussion of
what well we actually what I actually
mean when I say type I think like 90% of
the time just your sort of everyday
understanding is enough but yeah we need
a very concrete and precise definition
and that like my goal is to supply that
in the victus package we could do one
more quick question
thank you I also thought that the
factors were internally represented as
integers yet they were on separate trees
and the three trees that you mentioned
so is it not the case of their integers
in their normal representation or is
there something else that's different
there so that they are internally
represented as integers but you as a
data scientist should never be forced to
grapple with that like the fact that
when you concatenate them together
though that underlying of limitation is
exposed I think is a really bad thing
and to the idea of vectors is tickin ah
duh to hide you for that from that so I
notice there's there's a bunch of people
coming in for jeannie's talk so if there
is a seat next to you please move
towards the middle or do not be
surprised if the tiny verse suddenly
stops working on your computer
you
[Music]